Speaker 1: Fox News did town halls with the
Ohio Senate candidates.
That's Democrat Tim Ryan, currently a congressman
and Republican candidate J.D.
Vance during the Tim Ryan portion of the town
hall.
Tim Ryan did not back down from the Fox News
mob, and this is really interesting to see.
It's quite impressive.
In fact, this seems to be a stacked audience.
Some may be Democrats, but the lion's share
of the noise certainly was not pro-Democratic,
that's for sure.
And Tim Ryan turned what were initially boos
into at least some cheers on the topic of
January 6th.
Take a look at this.
Listen to the initial jeers and look at how
he turns it around and we'll talk about what
he does.
Speaker 3: They stormed the Capitol on January
6th.
They beat up 140 police officers.
Killed, killed one week.
They killed what?
They killed.
Unidentified: What do we do?
We all.
Well.
Speaker 3: We all.
We all watched.
We all watched it.
We all watched of it.
Speaker 1: Okay, so they boo.
But here he turns it around.
Yeah.
Speaker 3: We all watch a video and I think,
oh, I work at the finish, please.
And I work.
I'm happy to have this conversation.
I'm not afraid to have this conversation.
These are the conversations we need to have
in this country.
I welcome you guys.
Let's just be respectful.
But I'm not afraid to stand here and defend
my position.
On January 6th, 140 Kap, I. I sit on subcommittee
that funds the Capitol Police.
These are my friends.
140 of them got hurt, and some of them still
can't go back to work because they were beat
up with lead pipes.
They were sprayed with pepper spray, they
were beaten with flagpoles.
They were trying to overthrow the government.
They were trying to stop the peaceful transition
of the government.
What else were they doing?
They're going to kill Mike Pence.
Right on kill Nancy Pelosi.
Now somebody is beating up Nancy Pelosi's
husband with a hammer.
J.D.
Vance raised the money for the insurrectionists.
He made several social media posts to raise
money for them.
Now, I again, I don't care what your politics
are, but Americans should say, no, we have
to say no to that.
We're going to try to.
Speaker 1: Get as many questions.
All right.
So a smattering of applause.
What turned the tide here for him?
It's a couple different things.
Number one, Tim Ryan stood his ground.
He stood his ground.
He said, hold on, I'll go up against any of
you on the facts, but let's do it respectfully.
He backed up what he was saying.
It helped that he was telling the truth.
And then he found common ground with the audience.
And we're going to have I've told you all
before, we're very close to releasing a white
paper about how to have conversations about
politics that can be contentious.
We're going to give it away for free.
We've been working on it for weeks, giving
it away soon and finding common ground is
a really critical part of this.
One other element to this, Tim Ryan also getting
applause when talking about his answer on
energy policy.
Speaker 3: Tax that President Biden mentioned
a tax on oil companies profits.
Are you for that?
I haven't looked at exactly what he wants
to do.
I think the fact that oil companies are making
huge profits and having stock buybacks right
now while average person here is paying nearly
$4 a gallon, I think that's wrong.
And I think we need to crack down.
Unidentified: We need to crack down on.
I move on.
Speaker 1: So, I mean, listen, Tim Ryan is
not the most progressive, but he was able
to find common ground with a lot of these
folks.
And I think that that is instructive in many
ways, unfortunately.
If you believe the polling, J.D.
Vance is now up by about 2.2 points on average.
The important message is if you vote in Ohio,
make damn sure that you participate in this
election because Tim Ryan could win
this thing.